when you spend months predicting a
massive overwhelming Red Wave where you
say Republicans are going to win
everything and they're going to win
everything easily and then it doesn't
happen you have to start figuring out
who do you blame and the Republican
party is floating the idea of blaming
Donald Trump
increasingly over the last 12 or so
hours 12 to 16 hours since we started
getting results in in the midterms
Republicans have been slamming Trump for
the election disaster which will at best
be a red Ripple the Red Wave is gone
um the question now becomes does this in
any way impact Donald Trump's plans to
announce for 2024 there has been a
dramatic shift in the betting markets in
terms of who voters uh rather who
betters believe will be the eventual
Republican nominee let's take it step by
step and we actually go to
Fox News articles for this
Fox News article published early this
morning conservatives Point finger at
Trump after Republicans underwhelming
election results he's never been weaker
many conservatives say Tuesday's
election shows it's time to move on from
Trump
all the this is a quote from Michael
Brendan Doherty a senior writer at the
National Review
all the chatter on my conservative and
Republican channels is Rage at Trump
like I've never seen the one guy he
attacked before election day was
DeSantis the clear winner meanwhile all
his guys are
essing the bed
Real Clear Politics reporter Phil Wegman
says Republican Source tells me after
tonight with Trump candidates
underperforming and DeSantis winning by
double digits 2024 is a free-for-all
everybody in the water if you want to
take on Trump he's never been weaker
hmm
anecdotal tweets one user Max Nordo
Kerry Lake over Karen Robson Doug
mastriano over Lou Barletta Mehmet Oz
Over Dave McCormick J.R Majewski Trump's
big November 15 announcement should be
an endorsement of Ron DeSantis for 2024
we can do better the Reagan Battalion
time to move on from Trump
if DeSantis in Florida wildly
overperforms all the hand-picked and
trump-supported Republicans and other
swing districts particularly if they
lose well then gosh that is going to be
a fascinating new narrative that will be
commented upon by positively no one
another Fox News article Trump blasted
across media Spectrum over Republicans
midterms performance bigger loser
tonight remember we spoke last week with
Angelo Carrison and Angelo Carrison
agreed with my perspective on Fox Trump
and Republicans 2024. they're not
abandoning Trump yet
but they are setting up an escape hatch
an eject button call it what you will
wherein they are starting to seed
interviews with voters saying I kind of
like DeSantis over Trump they are
starting to publish articles about
others are saying Trump's time may have
come and gone
uh let's look at a little bit of uh of
this article as the midterm results
rolled in and the Red Wave long hoped
for had not materialized many pundits
and journalists pointed their fingers at
Trump
former Obama Campaign strategist David
Pluff on MSNBC said I think you have to
say Donald Trump has now presided over
two disastrous midterms
given the history of presidents in power
Democrats controlling all of Washington
inflation this should have been a much
stronger night for Republicans a bunch
of reasons for that but at the top of
them is Donald Trump he's deeply
unpopular he supported a bunch of
horrible Senate candidates who may end
up coughing up the football here
msnbc's Chris Hayes said Republicans
ascribe to Trump a totemic power he does
not have he screwed his own power he's
unpopular he screwed you today screwed
you it's not the full story but it is
part of the story and the sooner you
dump him the better it is for the
Republican party and American democracy
ABC's Jonathan Carl said it was unclear
who would control Congress but
Trump is the goat what I can and not the
greatest of all time
quote what I can tell you is The Biggest
Loser tonight is Donald Trump
one on CNN conservative commentator
Scott Jennings offered another blunt
analysis
uh saying quote there's a potential
narrative out of this night that if
you're a Discerning Republican voter
trying to figure out the future
direction of the party we once again
learned Trump is not a national winner
for the Republicans but DeSantis may be
the next evolution of someone who can
marry what you like about Trump but
recover some people that went away from
the party during Trump we'll link to
these articles and you can read all the
quotes Okay we don't yet have all the
results but it's not looking
particularly good
I'm going to show you a stunning number
for months and months and months Trump
has either been leading the betting
markets for 2024 Republican nominee or
tied with Ron DeSantis months and months
and months and months this is not a poll
okay this is People BET who do you
believe will be the Republican nominee
over the last few hours
Ron DeSantis has built the biggest lead
in the betting markets that he has had
this election cycle when you ask people
to bet on the question who will win the
2024 Republican Presidential nomination
the leader is now Ron DeSantis the way
this works is these are betting
contracts so with the santis you have to
put up 41 cents to win a dollar if it's
the santis whereas with Trump you only
have to put up 33 cents to win a dollar
the idea being
the more you have to put up to win a
dollar the more likely an outcome it is
this is we have not seen these numbers
at any point
it is the weakest that Trump has been in
years and the next question is does this
change Trump's plan to announce his
candidacy on Tuesday one of our sponsors
is monk pack making amazing granola bars
and the nut and Seed bars that are chewy
Sweet and delicious but I especially
love them because each bar has only one
gram of sugar two to three net carbs and
about 150 calories perfect if you do
keto or low carb or like me you're just
trying to stay conscious about sugar
intake you get the satisfying crunchy
salty sweet experience you were looking
for without the sugar monk pack comes in
flavors like sea salt dark chocolate
caramel sea salt they launched two new
flavors which are great peanut butter
cocoa chip and dark chocolate cocoa I
keep monk packed granola bars and nut
and Seed bars in the pantry at all times
they're great on the go for a quick
snack while your work working if you
don't love them as much as I and our
team do monk pack will refund all of
your money or exchange the product
whichever you prefer go to monkpak.com
and you'll get 20 off your first order
with the code Pacman at checkout the
link is down below